[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL CRAWFORD: Thanks
everybody for coming.
This is the Talks
at Google series.
We are very, very lucky to have
with us today Frances Stroh,
the author of "Beer Money: A
Memoir Of Privilege And Loss."
And we thought we
would kick it off
with having Frances do
a reading from the book.
Frances, thank you so
much for being here.
FRANCES STROH: Thank
you so much, Bill.
It's a great
pleasure to be here.
I obviously wrote a book about
what it was like growing up
in the Stroh family--
a big growing
family in Detroit--
beginning in 1850.
And I thought maybe
I would just talk
a little bit about the
trajectory of the business
before I--
BILL CRAWFORD: Please.
FRANCES STROH: --settle into--
BILL CRAWFORD: Absolutely,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
FRANCES STROH: --a reading,
because it will just
give a little bit
of context to what
I'm going to read, which
is actually personal,
family-oriented passage.
So my great great
grandfather, Bernhard Stroh,
came over from Germany in
1848 with a family recipe--
beer recipe, his family
had made in Germany--
and $150 in his pocket.
And he settled in
Detroit in 1850.
And he started brewing
beer in his basement.
And he sold it door-to-door
out of a wheelbarrow.
And he saved every spare penny
to buy a horse-drawn carriage.
He took the company
through prohibition
with his sons Julius
and Bernhard Jr.
They really took
over at that point,
and took the company
through prohibition
by selling malt syrup
for homebrewing purposes.
This was legal
during prohibition.
BILL CRAWFORD: Nice
loophole, yeah--
FRANCES STROH: Yes--
BILL CRAWFORD: --yeah.
FRANCES STROH: It was a
great loophole for many.
And also Stroh's ice
cream they started
producing during
prohibition, which
helped the family get through.
Julius, my great
grandfather, bought out
his brother's share
of the company
during the Prohibition years.
He was a really smart guy.
He bought the shares
for almost nothing.
And then the company
went gangbusters
when Prohibition was repealed
under Julius' continued reign.
And then my
grandfather, Gary Stroh,
took over the business
just before World War II.
And there was a very stubborn
streak in the Stroh family,
which is one of the reasons the
company survived in the family
for five generations.
And this really presented
itself in Gary's case,
when hops and wheat were
rationed during the war.
And Gary refused to water
down the beer formula
to keep volumes up, as every
other US brewer did, and really
just sold less beer,
but stuck to his guns,
and kept the strong beer taste.
Ironically, after the war
ended, American beer tastes
had changed.
And American consumers had
really, sort of, gravitated
at that point towards
the more watery beer.
Which is why Europeans made fun
of us for having watery beer.
Which of course is changing now
with the craft brew industry.
But in those days, people
wanted the watery taste.
When my great Uncle John
took over the company
after Gary died, he
watered down the beer.
Again the company
went up exponentially.
They bought Goebel.
They buy other brewers
in the Detroit area.
And then my uncle, Peter
Stroh, took the company over
in the late '70s, and decided to
grow through major acquisition
rather than small acquisition,
and, sort of, incrementally,
as we had done.
We were regional Midwestern
brewers still in the late '70s.
And what Peter decided to do was
purchase much larger companies
than Stroh's.
He purchased Schlitz.
He purchased Shaefer
in the early '80s.
We were $100 million market cap.
Schlitz was five times our size.
We took out a half a billion
dollar loan to buy it.
[WHISTLE]
And suddenly, we were a
big national powerhouse.
But we're still
family-owned and operated.
We were number three in
size behind Anheuser-Busch
and Miller.
And we-- people ask all
the time, what went wrong?
Well, our company
culture was still
family-owned and operated,
family-run board, still
sort of a regional
brewing mentality.
And overnight we were national.
We had breweries all
over the country.
And we didn't have
the marketing budget
to go that big that quickly.
So a variety of other
factors impacted
our success between 1982 and
1991, when we were Forbes 400,
and suddenly went from
being huge and seemingly
successful to almost
broke in about 10 years.
So that's really the,
sort of, thumbnail sketch
of what happened.
My book is about what it was
like growing up in the Stroh
family during those
years in the '70s,
'80s, and '90s, when the
company was really big,
and then lost everything,
and sold for scraps to Pabst
in the late '90s.
It's my coming of age
story as an artist,
as someone who is, sort
of, reflecting the family's
story in a variety
of ways in my work.
And it ties in the
fall out on the family,
in my branch of
the Stroh family,
what was happening
to the family members
as this beer story
was unfolding.
So that will bring me to this
passage, which takes place
in Grosse Pointe in 1980.
I was 13 years old at the time.
The December light
faded so suddenly I
could hardly read my own words.
Rather than switch
on the chandelier,
I slid my high school
application essay
across the dining table
closer to the bay window.
Snow was beginning to fall.
The empty house
creaked around me
as I bore down on my
paragraphs, determined
to get down exactly how things
had felt the summer before,
when everything changed--
it seemed-- overnight.
I wrote about my parents'
faces, pale and swollen
with sleeplessness,
and the knotted feeling
inside my stomach.
Something terrible
was happening.
My mother had given
up playing backgammon.
My father had stopped
leaving for work.
I described the hushed
voices, the closed doors,
my gnawing sense that everything
would come apart at any moment,
that only a barely discernible
tensing of all my muscles
might hold it together.
My parents sealed themselves
in the library for days.
Whatever you do, my
father said as he
pulled the door behind
him, do not come in here.
Whitney and I sat on the porch
watching TV, our blank faces
masking our alarm,
buoyed at least
partly by "The Brady Bunch,"
"Bewitched," "Happy Days."
My younger brother's auburn
hair was oddly disheveled,
his trousers an inch too short.
How I envied my older brothers,
both of them off to college,
Charlie a sophomore,
and Bobby senior.
On day three, my parents
emerged drained, older,
yet united in their conviction
that we should know the truth.
It's so awful to have to tell
you this, my mother began
in a cracked voice, the puffed
wedges underneath her eyes
by now a deep purple.
But it's important you know.
Your brother Charlie
is a drug dealer.
Her eyes filled up with
tears and she looked away.
My father dragged down his
cigarette dismissively.
We're taking him out of college,
putting him into the Marines
to clean him up.
As my mother wept, my
father put his cigarette
into the ash tray, and
gently rested both his hands
on her shoulders.
I couldn't remember the last
time I'd seen them touch.
You must never mention a
word about this to anyone
outside the family, my
mother said to Whitney and me
with unusual sternness,
wiping her cheeks
with the back of her
hand, nobody at all.
I felt the news and
accompanying emotions
seal themselves
off inside my body
with the ease of a
closing elevator door.
Drug dealers were
something you saw
on TV, not in my own family.
I remembered an episode of
"Starsky & Hutch," where
the drug dealer lived in
an abandoned apartment
on the outskirts of town.
Starsky kicked in the door
while Hutch aimed the gun.
I turned on the chandelier, so
that I could reread my essay.
Outside, the snow was
falling harder now,
and a few stray sparrows pecked
aimlessly at the frozen ground.
My last winter in Michigan--
next year I'd be gone,
away at boarding school
for ninth grade,
and away from house.
I'd been waiting to
go since sixth grade,
counting down the
years impatiently.
The applications all
asked for an essay
on an experience that
had changed my life.
And so while other
eighth graders
wrote about their
golden retrievers dying,
I wrote about
Charlie's drug bust,
and what I had done
to our family--
the shame and silence
spreading from my parents
to us, and then into just about
every aspect of our lives.
Charlie had been selling
cocaine, a drug I knew about
from Time Magazine.
I'd seen pictures of it-- lines
of white powder on the cover.
My parents had heard the news
from Charlie's college dean
earlier that year in the Spring.
He was expelled, and under
pressure from my parents
immediately enrolled in
Marine boot camp in San Diego,
leaving in early June.
But as June passed into July,
everything kept changing.
And the tension in the
house got only worse.
So at the end of the
summer, my parents
go out to San Diego for
Charlie's boot camp graduation.
On the day of the
ceremony, as I heard later,
my parents waited
in the auditorium,
holding their programs,
eager to see Charlie graduate
into his new life,
desperate to put
the whole ordeal behind them.
But when the Marines finally
filed in, clean and spiffed up
in their blue uniforms and
broad-brimmed marine hats,
my parents noticed that
Charlie was not among them.
Confused, my father
walked up the aisle
to look into the hallway.
There was Charlie, stiff
with fear in his uniform,
handcuffed and surrounded
by several federal agents.
My father went back
into the auditorium,
and took my mother
out by the arm.
Charlie was gone-- done for.
They drove back to
La Jolla, my mother
in tears, my father
shocked and humiliated,
both of them determined to
conceal from their hosts what
had happened.
Their worst nightmare
was unfolding.
Charlie's drug dealing would
surely make it into the papers
now, especially if he
ended up in prison.
Everyone in Grosse
Pointe would know--
everyone, everywhere.
I think I'll stop there.
BILL CRAWFORD: Thank you,
that's some powerful stuff.
FRANCES STROH: Thank you.
BILL CRAWFORD: So, something
that stuck out to me--
you know, your father
coming out and saying,
you know, tell no one-- right,
I mean, for obvious reasons.
It could bring embarrassment.
And--
FRANCES STROH: Of course.
BILL CRAWFORD: --it's
understandable.
So natural next question--
you wrote a book.
You wrote a book all about it.
And I know your father
is no longer with us.
But your mother still with
us, and several other family
members, right?
So what has been the
reaction from your family?
FRANCES STROH: Well, my--
Charlie is no longer with us.
My father is no longer with us.
My mother has been an
incredible support.
She's really had my
back from the beginning,
and, you know, handed
gallies out to her friends,
read the book out
loud to a friend
of hers who's lost her sight.
She comes to as many of
my events as she can.
So--
BILL CRAWFORD: That's nice.
FRANCES STROH:
--she's been amazing.
BILL CRAWFORD: That's great.
FRANCES STROH: And--
BILL CRAWFORD: Awesome.
FRANCES STROH: I
would say overall,
it's been positive-- the
relatives who I've heard from.
BILL CRAWFORD: Sure.
FRANCES STROH: The
book really focuses
on my branch of the Stroh
family, although it ties
in, of course, the
trajectory of the business,
and what happened, and how that
was tied to Detroit's destiny,
and, sort of, the
decimation of Detroit.
And some of the losses the
family experienced financially
was connected with that.
So it's all connected.
And yet the beauty of the
timing of when the story ends--
the story ends in 2009.
And by the time the book
was being published,
Detroit's Renaissance was in
the throes of its heights.
I mean--
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah.
FRANCES STROH: It's really
come together tremendously
in Detroit during the
time that the book was,
sort of, in the works
with the publisher.
And so it's been an
exciting period to,
sort of, come-- bring the
book forward at this time,
and also with Pabst relaunching
Stroh's beer in Detroit,
and everything that has, sort
of, really coalesced there.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah.
Yeah, no-- that's-- it's
almost like a nice way to, kind
of, look back on where
we came from as a city,
and Southeastern
Michigan as a whole.
So I mean, so on that, right--
I mean, near the
end of the book,
there is a little talk of
the decline of Detroit.
And you kind of said it.
But I mean, there is--
there's some kernels
of hope at the end.
And I think that that
has really kind of
been the harbinger in a great
way of all the great things
that are happening.
FRANCES STROH: That's right.
Yeah, I mention Music of
Contemporary Art Detroit,
the new wing at
the DIA, the fact
that the artists are moving in.
And really, it's always
when the artists come in,
we know that the city is coming
back, because then, you know,
the buzz starts to happen.
The restaurants come in.
The cafes, the
galleries, everything--
artists are always, sort of,
the canaries in the coal mine.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yes.
FRANCES STROH: So and of course
that was inspiring to me.
And as-- in that last scene
in the book, where my--
we've just left in
my father's funeral.
We're driving downtown.
We're watching-- you know,
seeing the places where
the houses are
being knocked down,
where there are holes
in neighborhoods.
The vegetables in
the gardens are
being planted to
make up for the fact
that there were no
grocery chains in 2009.
And of course that's all
changed dramatically.
But this feeling of rebirth,
and hope, and a resilience, that
really has been such a hallmark
of how I have lived my life.
I've wanted to-- and you
know, as I carved out my own
identity-- sort of separate
from the Stroh family story,
but then return to
it later in life--
BILL CRAWFORD: Sure
FRANCES STROH: --as I
have, to write the book,
and sort of reclaim that
history and my own way.
So Detroit I think has done
that in its own sense, as well.
And it's been an
amazing thing to watch.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah, no,
it's exciting for those
of us that are here living it.
So with that happening,
I mean, the timing
is serendipitous of
you writing the book.
Is that what spurred
you to write the book?
Or was there other factors
that drove you to-- it's
like, why now?
Why tell your story now?
FRANCES STROH: Well it
wasn't necessarily related
to what was going on
in Detroit at all.
In fact, when I
started the book,
nobody was talking
about Detroit.
It was right-- probably,
it was pre-bankruptcy.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah, or if--
FRANCES STROH: That's when--
BILL CRAWFORD: --they
were it wasn't--
FRANCES STROH: --national
attention started to, sort of,
really focus itself on
Detroit around the time
of the bankruptcy.
I was writing the
book because it
was a story I felt I'd always
known I wanted to write.
And somehow, when
my father died,
it opened the doors to do that.
There was just--
I'd been working on a
novel for several years.
Prior to that, I'd been
an installation artist--
and all through my 20s in fact.
And because my work
was so narrative
based as an installation
artist, in fact I had done--
the only piece I ever did
during those years that
involved family themes
was a piece that I
describe in the
prologue to the book,
where in a gallery space--
in a room inside a gallery--
there is a piece that I made
with all six of my family
members telling the family
story from each of their, just
very disparate points of view--
all at the same time on
six video flat screen video
monitors.
And it's this very
explosive experience
in the center of the room
with all of these voices
overlapping.
And that really was
one of the seeds
for this book that came later.
And perhaps even looking back on
the writing of the high school
application essay, the seeds for
the book were of course present
there, too.
So there's been a creative
impulse for a long time,
not just to tell my family
story and come to terms with it,
but just to, sort of,
penetrate the truth,
and really bring
things to light,
and understand things
on a deeper level,
and create meaning
out of events.
BILL CRAWFORD: Right.
Right, and so--
I wouldn't put this
on you necessarily.
I'll let you tell me.
This has been a pretty
cathartic experience
for you-- writing the book?
FRANCES STROH: I think that has
been one of the side effects
that has been wonderful.
It was never the intention.
But I did find through
the writing of the book
that I was able to make
connections between events
that I had never made before.
And the book is--
the story is told in a
very episodic way, where
each chapter is
essentially a snapshot
either of a period in my own
life, or in the family's,
or both.
I mean, I'm the narrator.
I'm always present for
these events in the story.
And so figuring out what those
events were very emblematic
of the overall story--
because of course, the part
stands in for the whole
in a book like this--
was an interesting process.
When I think about that
drive down into Detroit
as a teenager with
friends, and we'd
go and walk around the abandoned
Uniroyal tire plant, which
of course is something
that Detroiters
I guess have always done--
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah
it's a little bit
of a right of passage for--
FRANCES STROH: Continue to do.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah, yeah.
FRANCES STROH: Yes.
these old warehouses,
and old factories
are places that kids
still love to explore.
So we were doing that
back in the mid '80s.
And a so that drive
down to Detroit--
the experience of going in,
breaking in to this enormous--
almost city within a city-- the
abandoned Uniroyal tire plant--
and taking pictures.
We were all artists.
We were all, sort of,
reading the same books.
And then we go back
to Grosse Pointe
and, like, re-enter the fold
of our families' worlds, which
were so different.
And the contrast from
Detroit, Grosse Pointe--
you know, being with
friends, being with family--
all of that,
especially in my world,
it was sort of as if Detroit
was this escape that I really
needed.
I needed-- you
know, my father had
been an astonishingly
talented photographer.
I sort of carried that
torch forward in high school
and beyond.
And my father had gone
into the family business
instead of pursuing his dream
of being a photographer.
And a lot of Stroh
family members, I feel,
were pressured.
The men were pressured
to join the business,
didn't follow their dreams,
didn't necessarily play things
out, and carve out their
own identities in the ways
that perhaps they
would have liked to.
And I see this as one of the
pitfalls of family businesses
in general.
But certainly, in my
own family, things
unfolded I think in
a particular way.
Because there were people
working at the company,
people running the
company, who may not have
really wanted to be
there-- who would have
preferred doing other things.
BILL CRAWFORD:
That's interesting.
So I have two questions on that.
So-- the first being, and
you kind of touched on it--
I mean, hindsight being
what it is, what do you
think the Stroh family
could have done differently
to have kept in business.
I mean, you touched
on it a little bit,
but I would love to get
your thoughts on that.
FRANCES STROH: Sure, I feel that
during the '80s, certainly when
we went national, it was a big--
it was-- my Uncle
Peter essentially
decided to bet the farm.
It was his feeling that
we either had to grow--
"grow or go."
And that may have been true.
But growing that quickly,
and without the marketing
budget to take those brands
national, and really this ethos
of wanting the--
wanting it to continue to be
family-owned and operated,
to have this company there
so that their sons could
inherit it.
It was the attachment.
It was the over
identification with the brand
that was the problem.
We got a million offer
in the early '80s
for the company, which the
family-run board turned down.
Did I say million?
I meant billion.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah I was
like, you know, Frances,
it's probably good
they turned that down.
FRANCES STROH: A
billion dollar offer--
BILL CRAWFORD: Billion dollars.
FRANCES STROH: --which
back then, was $12 billion,
you know, in today's dollars--
BILL CRAWFORD: Easy.
FRANCES STROH: --if invested,
you know, in the S&P--
so turned it down.
And I think the
over-identification certainly
was present then, and continued
to be as we fought to survive
for the next 10 years.
Because almost as soon as the
offer was turned down, it--
things got pretty hairy in the
beer business, with price wars,
and shrinking margins, and
all kinds of other stuff.
So I really feel that if they
wanted to stay in the business,
it would have been better.
Like Bill Ford, he
knew when to step down
bringing in outside management.
We really didn't find the right
moment to, sort of, step aside,
and decided that we'd be
better off if somebody else was
running it and not
a family member.
BILL CRAWFORD: Interesting,
and so the other
question that you
spurred for me was,
so you had the males in the
Stroh family being encouraged--
despite whatever their
other interests may
be-- to go into the business.
But it seems like
from your book,
and things I've heard
you say, there wasn't
much of a path for the women.
FRANCES STROH: No, the
patriarchal lines of succession
were fixed.
That was how things were done.
And they-- I feel
as if, you know,
maybe it's more so in German
families than in others.
I just read about a
brewer in Germany.
They've been around
for nine generations.
And they just put the
first female family member
on the board.
So this is very, very common
in family-run businesses.
I think it's starting to change.
But no, the women in
the Stroh family or not
encouraged to join the business.
BILL CRAWFORD: Interesting.
FRANCES STROH: It just wasn't--
BILL CRAWFORD: Well--
FRANCES STROH: --part
of the conversation--
BILL CRAWFORD: Maybe that
would have made the difference.
Who knows?
FRANCES STROH: Perhaps.
BILL CRAWFORD: So
a lot of the book--
just pivoting off the
business for a second--
I want to talk
about entitlement.
That's especially pertinent to--
I think sometimes, like,
at Google, we forget
how lucky we are sometimes.
We're very, very lucky to
work at a place like this.
In your book, you talk about
a lot of the family members
receiving their dividend
checks that were just coming.
And, kind of, the expectation
was they would always come.
You seem to have, kind
of, been able to get away
from that entitlement.
And it's clear you've instilled
that in your son, Mishka.
How have you, kind of,
kept your head about that,
and been able to, kind
of, rise above the apathy
and entitlement?
FRANCES STROH: Well, I think
my mother was extremely helpful
when we were young.
Well, to begin with, my
father was a big spender.
He liked to live extravagantly.
He was a big collector of
art and various objects,
antique firearms, vintage
Leica cameras, guitars.
And my mother was very frugal,
and very careful with money.
Her motto was always
save for a rainy day.
And she really conditioned
us to understand that.
While she couldn't have known
what direction the company was
headed in, she certainly saw
that my father wasn't saving,
and that the future may
have not been so bright.
And she made us, sort
of, integrate this
into the very fabric
of our outlook on life.
So there was a feeling
of potential scarcity,
and at times real scarcity,
when she had to call our schools
and let them know the
tuition would arrive late,
or maybe even the phone
bill couldn't be paid,
because of my father's
extravagances.
BILL CRAWFORD: Wow.
FRANCES STROH: And so
there was this feeling
of great abundance--
in terms of what we
were surrounded with.
And yet, sometime-- and then,
there were these kidnapping
drills, where my father would
take me out on the sidewalk
in front of the
house, and train me--
as a young child-- to learn
how to not be kidnapped.
He would circle a
car around the block
while I waited alone,
terrified on the sidewalk.
And he would pull up next to
me and dangle a chocolate bar
out the window, and say--
in a scary voice--
come here, little girl.
And I would have run back
into the house crying,
as I'd been instructed to do.
And the reason for these
drills, as he said,
was we couldn't afford
to pay the ransom.
So there were very mixed
messages around money.
And so I feel as if I
internalized all of that.
And as I got older, of course,
there was this drive to--
I was just naturally an artist.
I always was for-- as a
young child, drawing--
as a teenager, a photographer--
in 20's, installation artist--
later became a writer--
so wanted to pursue that path--
and yet, always
knew that I somehow
had to figure out the
financial side on my own.
And especially when
my parents divorced,
and within several years
my father remarried--
and married my high
school classmate in fact--
the message was very
clear then that I had to--
I was very clear that I had
to figure it out on my own--
financially-- and
so taught myself
finance, and real
estate, and I was lucky.
My timing was good.
I was living in the Bay Area.
The real estate's
done very well there.
And so I was able to--
BILL CRAWFORD: Very well, sure.
FRANCES STROH:
--create a nest egg
that supports me to continue
to be a writer and an artist,
which has been very lucky.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very cool--
and so what-- you mentioned
you've gone through a couple
iterations as an artist,
as the installment artist,
and a writer.
What's next for you?
I mean, is writing--
is there more books?
Can we--
FRANCES STROH: Well I identify--
BILL CRAWFORD: --expect--
FRANCES STROH: --as a writer.
And I was-- so--
BILL CRAWFORD: OK--
FRANCES STROH: Yes--
BILL CRAWFORD:
--you identify as--
FRANCES STROH: --I'm--
BILL CRAWFORD: --a writer.
FRANCES STROH:
--working on a novel.
BILL CRAWFORD: Oh really?
FRANCES STROH: Yes.
BILL CRAWFORD: Can you divulge--
FRANCES STROH: I'm not--
BILL CRAWFORD: --any--
FRANCES STROH: --saying
a lot about it,
but it's definitely--
it's early stages.
And it's an exciting project.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very
cool, very cool.
So what-- like, what are
we thinking-- like, a year?
When can we keep
an eye out for it?
FRANCES STROH: Oh,
probably more than that.
BILL CRAWFORD: OK.
FRANCES STROH: Yes, it
took me about four years
to write "Beer Money," so--
BILL CRAWFORD: Really?
All right.
FRANCES STROH: Yeah,
I like to do draft
after draft to really get
the language exactly where I
want it.
BILL CRAWFORD: Perfectionist?
FRANCES STROH: I am.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very good.
And you talk about Detroit.
Now you've transplanted
yourself to San Francisco.
Any plans to take that
real estate prowess,
and bring it to the D?
FRANCES STROH: That's
a great question.
I've been thinking
about different options.
And I would love to.
BILL CRAWFORD: Good.
FRANCES STROH: It's a great
time to invest in Detroit.
And I can't say enough about
all of the exciting things
happening here.
So I actually
encourage the world
to come experience Detroit
in one way or another.
It's just so exciting to see
how the financial base is
so diverse now compared to
what it was when it was really
run by the automotive industry.
And then of course the city
suffered so dramatically when
they moved out.
And of-- you know, the
industry is still here.
But a lot of other industries
are moving in as well,
like Google, and like so
many other tech companies.
And so I feel as if it's a more
sustainable economic space.
BILL CRAWFORD: I would
completely agree with you.
FRANCES STROH:
Which is exciting.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very exciting.
Yes, well we would
love to have you.
We'd love to have your
investment in the city,
but we'd love to see more
of Frances Stroh around--
FRANCES STROH: Thank you.
BILL CRAWFORD: --Detroit.
Yeah.
OK, so final question--
a lot about the book is
about the business, and about
the family, and how those
two things intertwined.
Any-- it's certainly--
I read it almost
as a little bit of
a cautionary tale.
Do you see any similarities
between that situation
and, like, the Silicon Valley--
kind of, these, like,
inflated values,
and all these different things?
Is there anything we-- as
folks working at Google,
or working at Facebook,
or working at any of the--
LinkedIn, wherever--
any words of advice?
Anything to be careful of?
FRANCES STROH: Well
I would see more
of a parallel between Detroit
and the auto industry,
and you know, what
Detroit was at that time,
to Silicon Valley.
I see that parallel,
because it's really--
it's an industry
that defines an area.
In a way that Detroit was
defined by the auto industry,
Silicon Valley is
defined by tech.
That isn't necessarily
the case in a lot
of other American cities
or areas of the country.
The parallel-- I would
find more of a parallel
between my family's business
and other family businesses.
But the sense of hubris kind
of crosses all those barriers.
And I feel as if
that is something
that we all need to be
very, very vigilant about,
because the bubble mentality
is incredibly contagious.
And we lose perspective
very easily.
And suddenly,
things have changed.
And we didn't even know
that change was coming.
So appreciating what we have,
and the perseverance that--
you know, the founder's values--
I think of Bernhard's values.
If that could be carried
on through each successive
generation somehow--
I work with, now I consult
with family businesses
about how to get the
younger generation out
into the world after
college and build some grit,
and not have their
parents hand them jobs,
or call up their friends to
give them a job for a year
before they come back and work
at the family business, which
was how it worked in my family.
Send them out with a small
amount of money to get started,
and make them figure it out
on their own for 10 years.
It's only when we figure
out who we are in the world,
we follow a passion, or two, or
three, carve out an identity--
only then might
we have something
to offer our family's
business, or any other business
for that matter.
So that's my advice for families
and everybody else in business.
BILL CRAWFORD: Thank
you so, so much,
Frances for coming here from San
Francisco, through Detroit now,
to Ann Arbor to talk with us.
So yeah, we really
appreciate it.
thank you so much for your time.
FRANCES STROH: Thank you.
It's been a pleasure.
BILL CRAWFORD: This
has been amazing.
Very, very great.